a premier model has been added to the
head of Mercedes luxurious long-range
line of sedans the s-class the s63 AMG
is 30 kilowatts more powerful than its
predecessor but consumes zero point two
liters of gasoline less per 100
kilometers the car has been restyled for
more sportiness with a remodel chassis
less weight and 900 breathtaking newton
meters of torque and for the first time
there's all wheel drive for the AMG's
exclusive clientele it's not really see
one guy go from Mercedes explains that
the AMG 63 targets customers who
appreciate a large safe car but also
value power performance and a sporty
distinguished individual look under the
front and Bose I'll pass you a class the
whole appearance of the AMG s series is
sporty and sublime the headlights look
fierce the carbon fiber here is not just
for show it also cuts the cars weight by
100 kilograms to striking lines at
elegant flair to the sides the
understated rims are forged aluminium
undecided geiger notes at the sideskirts
seem to bring the car closer to the road
for exhaust pipes at the rear are a
typical trait that since the AMG apart
and the rear apron has a sporty look in
olin hamano spalding optic in da heck
filter assembly of the whole 5.5 liter
v8 biturbo engine is done by a single
mechanic
that's a tradition for the AMG the
engine is the s63 s highlight it
generates 430 kilowatts that can slam
the two-ton all wheel drive vehicle to
100 kilometers an hour in four seconds
top speed is electronically limited to
250 kilometers an hour the engine is
amg's most efficient 8 cylinder so far
but it still consumes 10.3 liters of
Super Plus to travel 100 kilometers
two large monitor screens also mean it's
easy for the driver to keep track of the
instruments and navigation
no my love is tough the s-class is
normally for long distance highway
driving but if you switch to sport
mountains and tight curves are a cinch
to the s63 comes in two lengths we're
testing the long version which is 13
centimeters longer than the shorter one
at five point 29 meters it still
performs astonishingly well on the kids
through switchbacks and the 4matic
all-wheel drive pays off when road
conditions are difficult the roomy
interior is dominated by the wide
dashboard wherever you look the
materials are the highest quality but
that's what you'd expect in this price
category
the digital combined instrument panel is
a colorful eye catcher the driver has
all the essential information at a
glance in the middle of the dash a fine
analog clock shows the precise time and
little time is needed to shift through
seven years thanks to the speed shift
paddles on the steering wheel the back
seat is very roomy to a trip in the AMG
is comfortable with the armrest down you
might think you're in a lounge electric
sunscreens reinforce that impression
so how much of a sports car is this
luxury sedan enact our test driver notes
that even 100 kilograms lighter the AMG
is still quite heavy and can't turn an
s-class car into a real sports car but
it doesn't aim or claim to so the AMG
has made the s-class a bit more
versatile but at a steep price the
version we tested will set you back more
than one hundred fifty two thousand
euros
Ford recently opened the gates of its
Belgian test track to journalists at the
wamu proving ground the automaker showed
off its latest assist systems designed
to make driving safer and easier first
we take a look at its enhanced Park
Assist system it allows the driver to
simply get out of the car and park it
from outside the vehicle I've been at
all this research engineer says to
imagine he's just come home and stopped
the car in front of the garage now he
can open the doors comfortably get out
of the vehicle and control it using his
smartphone dimms founded you know me in
a smartphone
dawn gets nice he wants the vehicle to
drive into the garage automatically but
he says it would also work with a
parking space he just presses the button
on the remote or the smartphone and the
vehicle starts to move as if by magic
the steering wheel turns guiding the car
into the garage 12 thoughtless and right
away the vehicle comes to a halt and the
engine should shut off then when he
returns to use the car again he just
uses the remote to back it out of the
garage again the fan video feed other
not seen less fat / look sets austega
haja have also found for security
reasons someone must sit in the
passenger seat when testing this
prototype but struggling to get in and
out of tight parking spaces could soon
be a thing of the past the Ford engineer
says he can open the doors wide without
fear of hitting anything get in the car
and drive away the early days Ford's
Park Assist could only parallel park an
ultrasonic sensor search for a suitable
parking space and took care of the
steering but the driver was still
responsible for accelerating and braking
then the system was expanded to include
perpendicular parking
normally lowish an asus Lee so Ford's
Pym fonda yok says the next logical step
was that the driver not even have to be
in the car at all he believes that in
many cases it's safer to be outside the
vehicle for instance on a busy street
it's much easier to see when traffic's
coming and stop trying to park he says
everything can be controlled by the key
or buy a smartphone another system of
the future is car to car communication
which allows for the transmission of
data from one vehicle to another it can
warn drivers who aren't breaking or have
stopped for no apparent reason the
system is based on simple wireless
technology if installed into many
vehicles it could save lives
the monster this research engineer
demonstrates how car-to-car
communication works he says the vehicles
can exchange data to get a better
overview of the current traffic
situation allowing forward to offer
various applications to improve safety
and traffic efficiency drivers are
informed much earlier and can avoid
potentially dangerous situations 79
green on zoom it can be out in five our
business we are in from urine on the 500
Watts even from iden fourth globe to new
Gotham Pontiac says Ford and the rest of
the industry believe that when vehicles
can tell one another where they're going
and how fast this could prevent many
accidents and represent a major
improvement in vehicle safety see a few
45-60 scheid cars could also recognize
deer crossing and warn the traffic
behind them about animals on the road in
future road construction sites could be
equipped with transmitters to warn
vehicles about the sites location and
changes to traffic routes that's
important because construction sites
increase the risk of accidents but Ford
would like the system to do even more in
terms of safety applications he says a
car receives data from other vehicles
about sudden braking for example in
future he could imagine the car would
automatically swerve to avoid a
collision
another Ford prototype can do this
already three radar units ultrasonic
sensors and the cameras can not only the
200 meters of road ahead of the vehicle
but also the neighboring lanes in case
the car needs to avoid an obstacle I
afonya this Ford engineer says here
we're approaching an obstacle such as
the end of a traffic jam the sensors
register it and warn the driver he says
if the driver doesn't react the car will
automatically swerve to avoid the
obstacle should the driver then start to
steer he can overrule the automatic
steering and sent the course himself
demon c'mon Zebedee digital for game
come but Ford's groundbreaking research
is not just restricted to assist systems
it's also developing alternative
propulsion systems for instance this e
wheel drive Fiesta is powered by two
wheel hub drives located in the rear
wheel arches they were developed by
automotive supplier schaeffler
the fiesta yogpod says his firm produced
the fiesta a wheel drive in conjunction
with fourth he calls it a development
center on wheels it uses chef leurs
wheel hub drive system which allowed
them to fit most of the engine
compartment into the wheel arches he
says everything you need to drive and
break can be found within the rims while
stresses that it's still a concept car
and represents the technology of the
distant future rather than tomorrow
while the engine technology the wheel
hub drive does not work and could be put
into series production he feels that an
entirely new vehicle architecture is
needed to highlight the strengths of the
car and its wheel hub dries and of
course that will take time molson guns
no fat so I stick to answer fussing when
thousands even tema doesn't fit about
you Bob but the Fords of the future
should be safe comfortable and emissions
free
Hyundai is launching the second
generation of the i-10 it's been
redesigned by the company's European
Development Center and whistles hi
Hyundai has moved production to Turkey
the exterior dimensions of the
subcompact of grown increasingly groom
in the backseat the quality of the eye
tends interior has been upgraded it now
has four feature levels and can compete
with higher classes of vehicle and
Germany the basic model will be
available for under 10,000 euros
starting in november Audi has given its
luxury limousine AAA the facelift the
most powerful and sportiest modeled the
s8 also profits from this it's four
liter TFSI motor produces 382 kilowatts
and a maximum torque of 650 Newton
meters it's prints from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour and just 4.1 seconds
a real highlight of the new s8 is its
headlights and matrix LED technology
with precision electronic control and
dynamic linkers in Germany the new s8
starts at one hundred fourteen thousand
seven hundred euros
you
Suzuki's sx4 s-cross is the latest
addition to the carmaker's selection of
models the new version is distinctly
larger and more comfortable than the
previous sx4 which will still be
available in a classic version we're
testing an 88 kilowatt diesel the broad
range of features stand out the a 60s
cross hops turn macalinski from Suzuki
touts the large 430 litre trunk and a
full range of what are usually extras
even in the basic version for example
cruise control a speed limiter a
standard start/stop system and air
conditioning and more is available for a
bit more money our test car has a
navigation system to zone automatic air
conditioning heated leather seats front
and back and electric windows all around
and there's an extra in the
top-of-the-line model available in
Germany that our test driver Montes
karad is crazy about as unless look if
he loves the huge panoramic glass
sunroof it opens very wide providing a
feeling almost like a convertible but
then you have to live with the sound of
the wind you're feeling fresh food
Aladin Alyssa Milano with I haven't
coercion later the sx4 s-cross is
available with front or intelligent
all-wheel drive with special programs
for snow and sand but it's most at home
on the road it needs 12 seconds to
sprint up to 100 kilometers an hour fuel
consumption in the two-wheel drive
diesel model averages four point two
liters per 100 kilometers the cars
dynamics are satisfied
the clan is car test driver says he
can't complain about the power provided
by the little 1.6 litre diesel engine in
the sx4 he is driving mokona a gasoline
engine is also available also with 88
kilowatts of power and fuel consumption
of five point four liters per 100
kilometers the exterior has an off-road
look with matte silver trim on the front
as well as on the rear and the door
sills the car clears the ground by about
17 centimeters
the standard trunk holds 430 litres of
luggage that's nothing to sneeze at
it's enough for a country outing with
the family but on winding country roads
the springy suspension makes itself felt
monta says he personally would prefer
tighter steering but reflects that the
buyer of an sx4 s-cross is probably not
planning to race with it anyway Montes
found no real weaknesses in the sx4
s-cross everything is solidly crafted
nothing creaks I rabble's the starting
price for the compact crossover in
Germany is nineteen thousand four
hundred ninety euros depending on the
extras and drivetrain this can rise to
as much as thirty thousand euros
what the conductor Chester says the
almost 20,000 euros starting price may
seem a bit high to some potential buyers
especially because there is competition
in this segment but he says that if you
consider the equipment and furnishings
here it's still a good offer done it's
the stuff we don't go to sanger vote
the original VW Beetle wasn't very fast
or flashy though it was reliable but
even a bug can change its spots as nkf
our test driver says it might seem a bit
laughable to have a robar bucket seats
and a racing harness and a beetle but
then this isn't just any VW Bug it's a
rally beetle and he's going to find out
more about it they said he heard my
house Finn
even though Volkswagen designed it as an
affordable family car in the 1960s and
70s skillful mechanics transformed the
little beetle into a pocket rocket
I thought I'd Minnelli Krista Bauer says
that the tuners and stylists really did
a makeover on this rally beetle the 145
horsepower engine propels you up the
mountains she says so much so that your
tears of joy are shed horizontally the
first souped-up beetles appeared in 1951
seven years later Te'o Decker made a
business of it and the workshops of T de
or Te'o Decker Essen he produced almost
all the parts used to tune beetles
himself school Towson from our test
driver says the last original model
beetle rolled off the assembly lines in
Mexico in 2003 he notes few external
changes were made to turn this one into
a rally car like these headlights and
the extra oil cooler but he says the
really sporty parts are underneath the
chassis and the motor here they board
the cylinders to get as many cc's as
possible and installed two big
carburetors but our tester Warren's
Germans wanting to soup up their old
Beatles to do it in a way that fits the
cars era or the vehicle inspection
agency could revoke its vintage car
status helmets with awesome epic hint
naturally our beetle from the site house
car museum in Wolfsburg was tuned
according to Teo Decker's original
methods this little powerhouse has a top
speed of 170 km/h in its day it sold for
some 18,000 marks around three times as
much as the basic model the spare
cockpit attest to its Motorsports status
as does its two-liter 145 horsepower
boxer engine
while performance at the lower engine
speed range is still quite restrained
the motor really comes into its own
starting at 3,000 rpms Christophe says
it's not just the powerful engine and
the sound that let you know this bug was
meant for motorsports he says the brakes
are extremely stiff and so is the
suspension which means there's even a
hint of comfort but he says that's not
what this car is about it's about
Motorsports the beetle was never
designed to be an off-roader even on the
car is robust and reliable enough to
take quite a beating the assault sport
beetle Road motorsport history scoring
many victories and rallies between 1966
and 1973
that's a kpop christo says that while
it's clear the beetle was a
groundbreaking car this rally beetle did
one better and help the most famous and
beloved Oaks wagon of all time make the
leap into motorsport so it's a true
milestone in automotive history and my
inspired definitive souped-up compacts
are common on German roads today
following the trend kicked off by the
rally beetle
you